السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اثارت نتائج
الانتخابات التشريعيه الهولنديه موجه من
الارتياح بين قاده المانيا وفرنسا ومسؤولي
الاتحاد الاوروبي ارتياح عكسته تصريحات
اعتبرت ما فرضه الناخب الهولندي انتصارا
لاوروبا على تيارات اقصى اليمين التي
انتعشت احلامها بالسيطره على القاره
العجوز خاصه بعد خروج لندن من الاتحاد
الاوروبي وفوز دونالد ترامب بالرئاسه
الامريكيه في الوقت الذي توعد فيه زئ اقصى
اليمين الهولندي خيرت فيلدرز خصومه بجولات
انتخابيه قادمه تتجه الانظار الى كل من
فرنسا والمانيا متسائله عما ينتظر قوى
اقصى اليمين في المواعيد الانتخابيه
المرتقبه في البلدين نتعمق بالنقاش في هذه
القضيه بعد تقرير الزميله مريم
ابيش اقوى لا ربما في تاريخ هولندا لا
لاقصى اليمين قال الناخبون استيقظ
الهولنديون على اخبار سرت خصومه خيرت
فيلدرز بعد فرز اصوات انتخابات تشريعيه
شدت اليها انظار كل دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي وصل صد هذه الحنا المحتفله بفوز
حزب يمين الوسط الى باقي دول القاره
العجوز وامريكا تنفس اخيرا رئيس الوزراء
مارك روتي السعداء وتقاسم الفرحه مع انصار
حزب الشعب من اجل الحريه
والديمقراطيه في هذا المساء قالت هولندا
بعد خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
والانتخابات الامريكيه لا لل الشعبويه
الخاطئه قبل ساعات من فتح مراكز الاقتراع
كانت كل استطلاعات الراي تشير الى احتمال
تقدم حزب الحريه بزعمه فيلدرز المتطرف بد
ان الناخب الهولندي اطاح باحلام اقصى
اليمين للسيطره على البرلمان وتشكيل
الحكومه تجاوزت نسبه المشاركه في الاقتراع
80% وهي الاعلى في البلد منذ عشر سنوات
وفي النتائج التي ستعلن رسميا الاسبوع
المقبل يحتل الصداره حزب الشعب من اجل
الحريه والديمقراطيه لثالث مره على
التوالي اذ حاز على 33 مقعدا في البرلمان
الذي يتكون من 150 مقعدا وجاء حزب الحريه
المتطرف في المرتبه الثانيه ب 20 مقعدا
بزياده خمسه مقاعد عن انتخابات 2012 حل في
المرتبه الثالثه حزب النداء المسيحي
الديمقراطي والديمقراطيين 66 بعد ان حصل
كل منهما على 19 مقعدا حاول فيلدرز امتصاص
مراره الهزيمه عبر تغريدات مستفزه كعادته
قائلا انه يفخر بالنتيجه وبان روتي لم
يتخلص منه
بعد يتلخص برنامج فيلدرز في صفحه واحده
باغلاق الحدود امام المهاجرين ومنع بيع
الصحف واغلاق المساجد في بلد يشكل
المسلمون 5% من سكانه الانتخابات كانت
مقياسا لانتخابات منتظره في فرنسا
والمانيا ونتيجه هولندا قد تؤثر كثيرا على
مزاج الناخب في هذين البلدين بفرحه
وارتياح كبيرين استقبل مسؤولون اوروبيون
كثر الخبر اكثرهم سعاده المسؤولون في
الاتحاد الاوروبي والمستشاره الالمانيه
انجلا ميركل واحزاب يمين الوسط
الفرنسيه للحظه اعتقد اقصى اقصى اليمين في
اوروبا ان هذه السنه ستكون لتحقيق احلامهم
وبان خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
وفوز ترامب تمهيد لعصر الشعبويه وفي لحظه
تاريخيه اختار الهولنديون قيم الحريه
والتعايش والانفتاح على الاخر اهي بدايه
عوده اوروبا الى رشدها بعد صيف مجنون هدد
بجنون اكبر في عده دول المؤكد انه عكس
البريطانيين والامريكيين لم يستيقظ
الهولنديون على
كابوس يضم الينا من برلين استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه برلين الحره الدكتور
كارستن كوشمار وم ليون في فرنسا عبر سكايب
المحلل السياسي الفر لويم مرحبا بالضي
الكريمين السيد دكتور
كشد بالمعايير الانتخابيه الهولنديه كيف
لنا ان نصف النتيجه التي حصل عليها حزب
الحريه الذي
تزعمه في انتخبات
هول قد فاز لنحصل على بعض المقا ون جانب
اخر لم يحقق النتيجه التي كان يتمناها فقد
كان يقول بانه سيفوز
في المرتبه الاولى لانه اعظم حزب وتالي
فهذه النتيجه ليست نجاح كامل له رغم ان
نتائجه في الاستطلاع الشهر الماضي كانت
مختلفه وكبيره وبالتالي نجد انه اصيب
بخيبه امل ولكن هل هي فعلا هزيمه هل يمكن
اعتبرها هزيمه لدر رغم انه تقدم بخمس
اصوات على الانتخابات
السابقه خمسه مقاعد
نعم كلا كلا انها ليست هزيمه حقيقيه الامر
يعتمر على يعتمد على وجهه النظر لقد فاز
بعض المقاعد الاضافيه ولكن لم يحقق
النتيجه التي كان يتمناها او يتوقعها اذا
فمن ناحيه يمكن القول انها فوز بالنسبه له
لكن ليس بالدرجه الكبيره التي كان يتوقع
مع السيد بيير لوي ريمون كيف نفهم هذه
الثقه الكبيره التي اصبح يتمتع بها ويحظى
بها اليمين المتطرف في اوروبا في كل
مناسبه انتخابيه في السنوات الاخيره صحيح
ان هذه المناسبات
الانتخابيه اخي عبد الصمد تخلق الحدث لن
اقول بالضروره المفاجاه لان هناك مع الاسف
موجه مد شعبوي
اصبحت يركبه اكثر من زعيم حسب ولكن في نفس
الوقت وانتم ذكرتم في بدايه التقرير ان
فرنسا وال المانيا عبرت عن ارتياحهما من
هذه النتيجه انا في الحقيقه لن اكون
بالضروره متفائلا الى هذه الدرجه فربما
اقول اكثر بان هذه المره من جديد احتوي
الموقف احتواء ولكن ليس هناك من ضامن في
ان هذه الموجه الشعبويه لن تتصاعد
هناك عده عوامل في الواقع
يمكن اليام بها مساله الهجره مساله طبعا
هذه المعارضه الذي يبديها قطاع من الشعب
في
وجه اجنبي مثل هذه الامور المتعلقه ايضا
بتطور المستوى الاقتصادي وان كان في
الحقيقه ايضا في هولندا مؤشرات تدل على ان
الوراد اقتصاديا في الواقع يعيش حاله من
الرخاء النسبي بررت ربما ان اليمين الوسط
تمكن هذه المره من الفوز بالانتخابات وان
وان بقي مهددا ومساله هذا المد الشعبوي
المتصاعد موجه تكتسح اوروبا وخاصه طبعا
الدول المركزيه فيها فرنسا والمانيا وهناك
تخوفات فعلا من وجود ادان صاغيه لمثل هذه
التيارات السياسيه
نعم مد شعبوي تقول سيد دكتور كارسن مد
شعبوي يقول بيير لوي ريمون ملحوظ في
اوروبا لكن ايضا ما هو ملحوظ الان في
هولندا ان هناك حزب ارتبط بشخصيه
فيلدرز الشخص الوحيد الذي يمثل هذا الحزب
في الخارج وهولندا حينما يذكر سياسيه
دائما ما يقفز هذا الشخص في في
مقدمه الذاكره في المقدمه ماذا يعني
لهولندا انك ان يكون فيلدرز هو واجهتها
السياسيه نستطيع ان نقول من جانب ان
الهولنديين وضعهم الاقتصادي جيد وهم
استفادوا من الهجره ومن الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولكن ليس كل الشعب الهولندي يستفيد من ذلك
لذلك هناك بعض الناس غير راضين من الوضع
الاقتصادي في البلاد وغير راضين عن تدفق
اللاجئين ويجدون الصعوبه في التكيف مع
الوضاع المتغيره وهم يقولون دعونا نبقي
اجانب خارج البلاد ونترك الاتحاد الاوروبي
او على الاقل لا نعطي الاتحاد الاوروبي
مثل هذه الصلاحيات والسلطات الكبيره وهذا
ما يقوله من يؤيد فيلدرز وهم نفس النوع
الذين في دول اوروبيه اخرى صوتوا لصالح
الشعبويين واليمينيين متطرفين ولكن ه هل
يمكن هذه الاحزاب اليمنيه فعلا ان تراهن
على
هذا الرهان الشعبويه الى اي حد يمكن ان ان
يمضي بعيدا ربما في انتخابات قادمه لان
هذا المدى الشعبوي لم يكن ملحوظا بهذه
الدرجه وبهذه الحده في الانتخابات السابقه
الان بات يتصدر المشهد وبات صوت عاليه في
الانتخابات
اعتقد ان مدى امكانيه توسعهم ومدى نجاحهم
في المستقبل يعتمد لحد كبر على النظام
الانتخابي فقد شهدنا في على سبيل المثال
في الولايات المتحده هناك مرشحان فقط
وبالتالي فيكون هذا يعطي فرصه كبيره
للشعبي اما في هولندا فهناك احزاب مختلفه
كثيره حصل نتيجه جيده سيحصل على 20 في
المنتخبات القادمه وكن يحصل على الغالبيه
وبالتالي اذا رفضت الاحزاب
الاخرى اجراء ائتلاف معهم فلن يصبح رئيس
وزراع في المانيا الوضع نفسه فذلك لدينا
احزاب كثيره ولدينا ايضا ائتلاف هناك ما
يسمى البديل هناك حزب اليمين الالماني
المسمى البديل الالماني لن نستطع تشكيل اي
ح
معي حزب اما في فرنسا فانه في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه سيبقى
مرشحان فقط ونحن لا نتوقع ان م لوبين
ستفوز لكن رغم ذلك يبقى الامر ممكنا لان
هناك فقط مرشحان وبالتالي كل شيء يصبح
ممكن لوبين لن تفوز سي ب ليمون يقول ضيفنا
في في بلين ولكن كيف كان لهذه النتائج
نتائج الانتخابات وهذا الصعود الواضح
لليمين المتطرف في هولندا كيف كان كانت
اضاءه في فرنسا فرنسا التي تعيش ايضا على
على يعني ايقاع تصاعد كبير للمد
اليميني عبد الصمد هذا الصدا هذا الايقاع
هذا التصعد طبعا تسعى مب استغلاله وفي اخر
تصريح انها ادت بها لوسيله الاعلام
الفرنسيه تحدثت عن ان النظام الحاكم في
هولندا نظام يتزعزع
وبان هذا
تصاعد لفيرس يعكس ديناميه ولكن في الواقع
هناك ضوابط في فرنسا اعتقد انها لا تزال
قائمه فضلا عنما ذكره الضيف من كون نظام
الانتخابي فرنسا لا يعتمد على النسبيه
وبالتالي ليس مجبرا على اقامه تحالفات مما
هو الحال في المشهد الهولندي هناك ما يسمى
بالجبهه الوطنيه الجبهه الجمهوريه عفوا
الجبهه الجمهوريه التي يمكن ان تلعب دور
كثير الامواج ولكن بطبيعه الحال هذا لا
يبعد شباح وصول ي يوما ما الجبهه الوطنيه
الى سده الحكم هناك اليات في الجمهوريه
الفرنسيه هناك ضوابط تجعل
من حس المواطنه حسا مت ستخا يدفع
بالناخبين التقليديين
لحزب معين ان يهب
ل
التصويت نعم ولكن سيد سيد بيغ لوي ولكن
سيد بي ولكن يلاحظ ايضا كما شهد في تبعنا
في هولندا ان حتى في فرنسا كان
اليمين الوسط واليمين مختلفان من حيث حده
المواقف سواء من الهجره سواء
من قضايا الامن وقضايا ايضا العلاقه مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي الان اصبح حتى قادت
الوسط واليمين يستميل القاعده الشعبيه
لليمين المتطرف بتبني خطاب اقرب الى
اليمين المتطرف الى اقصى اليمين ولكن هناك
وسط غير وسط اليمين متساعد ايضا في فرنسا
وهو وسط اليسار وسط جديد يقف وراءه
ايمانويل ماكرون يتخذ موقفا مغاير من
مساله الهجره من مساله الاتحاد الاوروبي
من مساله المهاجرين ويلقى اذانا صاغيه
خاصه انه قد يستفيد من الفضائح التي ورط
نفسه فرونسوا فيون فيها والذي فعلا فيون
حاول ان يستغل جناحا من من اقصى اليمين
التقليدي فلم يفلح ف فضلا عن هذه الفرصه
المواتيه لصعود تيار اوماش السياسي الجديد
هناك اذان صاغيه ايضا في اتجاه اخر اتجاه
الشعب وليس اتجاه شعب هذه المره يدرك
تماما بان برنامج الجبهه الوطنيه اقصى
اليمين الفرنسي لا يمكن ان يؤدي الى ادنى
اصلاح
اقتصادي ان التحول من العمله الاوروبيه
الموحده
الى الذي
تقته يل الى افشال فرنسا كقوه تنافسيه في
العالم وان لا برنامج يمكن ان يؤسس على
رفض الهجره والمهاجرين ما دام معظم
المهاجرين المقيمين عندنا بفرنسا فرنسيون
مثلنا وينتجون في الرخاء الاقتصادي
يساهمون فيه دكتور كارسن في الختام اوروبا
بهذا المد الشعبوي الذي يبدو وكانه يتقوقع
حول المواطنه وحول الدوله القطريه هل هذا
المد يهدد كيان الاتحاد الاوروبي كجسم
موحد له مشروع
واحد نعم اعتقد ذلك واعتقد ان الخطر
يكمن الخطر هو
اقل يزداد اذا ما وصلت هذه الحركات
الشعبويه الى السلطه ولكن كما قلت في
هولندا لن يستطيع الوصول الى السلطه حتى
لو حققوا نتيجه 30 بالانتخابات وبالتالي ف
فاحتمالات ان يصبح اي رئيس وزراء او رئيس
منهم في الدول الاوروبيه احتمال ضعيف جدا
وبد لكن الخطر يكمن هو في في الاحزاب
الوسط احزاب التي ليسوا في اقصى اليمين
اذا ما تبنوا بع ب مواقف وافكار الاحزاب
الشعبويه اليمينيه لكسب اصوات هؤلاء
الناخبين فهم ايضا يقولون نحن لا نريد
الاتحاد الاوروبي ونحن نفضل ان مواطنينا
يكون مفضلين على اوروبيين و وان فكره
التضامن هنا مع داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
بدات تضمحل قليلا لان كل الحكومات تحاول
ان تسير على نهج وطني
عازب الشعبويه وهذا هنا ي الخطر على
الاتحاد الاوروبي شكرا لك دكتور كاستن كوش
مدر من برلين استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه برلين الحره ونشكر ايضا مليون عبر
سكايب المحلل السياسي الفرنسي ب لوي
غم كثيرون يتحدثون عن نظام الفص العنصري
الذي اخضعت اسرائيل الفلسطينيه له لكن
عندما يوثق تقرير الاسكوا ذلك يتخذ
الموضوع ابعادا اخرى ويثير ردود فعل
ستتوقف عندها زميله غاده عويس في الملف
الثالث من حصاد اليوم